[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous allons à la rencontre
de Wilfried qui a bénéficié du
dispositif FSL le fond de solidarité
pour le logement à travers une mesure
d'accompagnement sociale du logement la
SL allons voir ça
[Musique]
nous sommes à Saint-André pour retrouver
Wilfried qui a pu bénéficier d'un
accompagnement social lié au logement
l'asll dans le cas du dispositif de fond
de solidarité pour le logement pour
l'aider à résorber une dette de loyer
allons à se rendre compte pour qu'il
nous en dise un peu plus
[Musique]
social dans le cas du FSL raconte à nos
commandes du parler de ce dispositif et
quels sont les démarches qu'on a fait
pour pouvoir en bénéficier alors je suis
bien une en acte téléphonique il y a
quelques années suite à ça j'ai déposé
une plainte avant et j'ai signalé à la
CAF que j'étais endetté et moi orienté
vers le Conseil Général puis une
association et puisse réunion donc j'ai
eu un accompagnement social et que
mon conseiller de faire un FSL ce que
j'ai fait ils m'ont accompagné dans tous
mes démarches c'est un dispositif qui
m'a aidé à gérer que ce soit socialement
ou bien psychologiquement
l'accompagnateur social bon la prouve à
moins
confiance il a pas juge à moi et suite à
ça ben voilà et maintenant des projets
maintenant
et mes dettes sont effacées contre
partie
dans nos témoignages on peut comprendre
que ce n'est pas que une aide financière
c'est aussi un accompagnement social que
les très important oui puisque toute
façon nous créole généralement on n'aime
pas demander d'aide on n'aime pas
demander effectivement on est assez fier
et il faut dire aussi qu'on a honte de
dire voilà on a besoin d'aide donc de
faire ce geste là c'est important merci
beaucoup Wilfrid merci à vous moi
[Musique]
regroupe plusieurs aides allons à la
rencontre de Madame vidote de ville qui
va nous en dire un peu plus sur ces
différentes aides pour journalier
quelles sont les différentes aides
proposées par le FSL alors le FSL donc
CDZ financière donc il peut avoir les
aides que l'évier à l'entrée dans le
logement c'est-à-dire tout ce qui est
dépôt de garantie premier mois de loyer
les frais d'ouverture compte euros
Energie etc et puis il y en a aussi des
aides ben c'est pour pouvoir rester dans
le logement parce que des fois il y a
des dettes de loyer donc aider à
résorber les dettes de loyer et puis
aussi s'il y a des factures impayées
d'eau d'énergie
téléphonie et puis aussi internet donc
voilà un petit peu les aides mais après
n'a aussi un volet que qui concerne
l'accompagnement social
qui peut bénéficier de ce dispositif
donc c'est toute personne que les en
difficulté particulière justement et bon
bien évidemment on a un règlement
intérieur on a des conditions notamment
de ressources etc et donc le ménage s'il
veut faire une demande la famille elle
va elle va aller voir un travail au
social et puis que va faire une
évaluation sociale que va voir si son
caï rentre dans le FSL que va monte un
dossier avec la famille et puis ensuite
tu as envoyé ça au fait celle-là au
service que j'ai le FSL et il a une
commission technique que va décider ben
si il y a un accord ou pas par rapport à
la situation de la famille donc c'est
vraiment au cas par cas et selon une
évaluation sociale oui exactement merci
[Musique]
dans le cadre d'un plan d'aide
coordonnées et organisé en lien avec la
famille en prenant en compte la capacité
contributive et les partenaires
susceptibles d'intervenir le FSL peut
venir en complément des dispositifs de
droits légaux de la CAF de la CGSS ou
des aides potentielles mises en place
par le CCAS ou les associations
[Musique]
avoir plus d'informations sur le fond de
solidarité pour le logement n'hésitez
pas vous avez toutes les coordonnées qui
s'affichent en bas de votre écran le
dépassement des générations c'est fini
si vous voulez revoir cet épisode ainsi
que des épisodes précédents rendez-vous
sur nos sites et nos réseaux sociaux
quant à moi je vous retrouve très vite
pour un nouvel épisode à bientôt
la semaine prochaine je vous amène sur
le terrain de Monsieur Payet un
agriculteur qui a bénéficié de l'aide de
balance une aide du département qui
souhaite accompagner les producteurs
indépendants de fruits et légumes à nous
le verrons
[Musique]